واعترف المتحدث باسم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي دانييل الهجاري بان الجنود
يمرون باوقات صعبه ومعقده ويتعرضون لمواقف
غير مسبوقه في العمليه العسكريه المستمره
في قطاع غزه اضاف ااري ان الجيش يواجه
امورا لم يتعرض لها من قبل وكان ان
التحقيق بشان قتل ثلاثه اسرى اسرائيليين
برصاص الجيش مستمر وثمه عمليات خاصه
لاعاده الاسرى
احياء ونحن في قمه حرب
و ولجنا اوضاع صعبه
ومعقده وايضا هناك بعض الامور الصعبه لم
نراها من قبل هناك عمليات خاصه من اجل ان
ننقذ المخطوفين هناك الحدث يجب ان نتعلم
به ولذلك نعمل على مدى 24 ساعه للتحقيق في
هذا الحادث من رئيس الاركان وحتى المحارب
الاخير في الميدان نحن ندرس هذا هذه
الحادثه وايضا في نهايه الامر يجب ان نؤكد
على النود المحاربين في الميدان على
التاكيدات لان نحصل على ظروف وفرص اخرى من
اجل اعاده المخطوفين